i cha dr. David Eggers joins us from his
home in Los Angeles David very good to
see you I want to pick up on Ben's
report about that hydroxychloroquine
because there certainly seems to be a
big difference of opinion between the
president and the doctors on his on his
team and as the president keeps pointing
out he is not a doctor so what is the
benefit what is the risk of using this
this anti malaria drug whose right here
so hydroxychloroquine has been used for
over three decades from malaria and I
think more importantly for lupus here in
this country it is a remarkably safe
drug when you give it for lupus we don't
even check if nobody has a history of
heart problems classically you don't
even check the heart and we're talking a
period here of giving it for less than a
week or maybe a little bit more in some
cases so the safety is there the problem
is the data showing it works were a
rather small study in France and one in
China the studies the data was there the
question is where the studies well done
the answer is no where the studies
definitive no so do we know it really
helps this disease no but when you look
at potential upside and potential
downside I mean it's certainly in the
right cases makes sense to take that
risk and use these drugs we're at war
now and sometimes we don't have all the
evidence we need talking about being at
war I want to talk about what the
Surgeon General said because it was very
ominous he says get ready for our 911
Pearl Harbor moment was very frightening
to hear those words what should we be
preparing for this week you know I'm
just afraid of this week I mean this is
a week we're gonna see a growth in the
number of deaths across the country
we're going to see certain cities really
explode and you know I all of us you
know fear this it happens to all of us
have a friend or somebody we know who's
affected by this virus it takes about
two and a half to three weeks from
interventions to actually yield a
flattening and then a decrease in the
curve so my hope and prayers are this is
the last week till the interventions we
all made start to kick in and we see a
drop in the number of deaths and a
flattening of that curve and then a
major decline dr. Bracci also said
something very interesting on TV
yesterday he
half the people infected may not have
the symptoms and that's much larger than
the estimate then what the CDC has told
us so what does this tell us about this
virus Gail I mean this is this is
telling us this is an insidious virus
that we've seen nothing like it
he said 25 to 50 percent of the people
can be asymptomatic when you're
asymptomatic you feel fine you go out
you do things you wouldn't have done you
take risks that probably are not
appropriate and hence the dramatic
spread across this country and it
certainly scares me when you see you
know areas where they appear in
Washington we saw pictures of this
weekend when you see church services
people going out they don't want to hurt
anybody but they don't know they have
the virus if there's one thing that is
universal it is that we are all scared
thank you very much David egg is always
good to see